. Last Wednesday was a very important day
because we had an article published in The
Atlantic about Donald Trump's plan to steal
this election should he lose to Joe Biden.
We talked about it.
The plan is to use allegations of fraud to
justify Trump choosing Republican electors,
even in states where Joe Biden won by saying,
well, Joe Biden didn't really win because
of fraud.
So I'm going to send Republican electors or
ask the state legislature to send Republican
electors.
This would be done in conjunction with the
use of lawyers to stop the counting of absentee
ballots on Election Day.
This is a major story.
This is a story of a desperate sitting president
with a very specific plan to subvert the will
of the people to destroy democracy.
You would think that that would be 24/7 coverage
because it is a red alert disaster.
And yet The New York Times put a story about
it on page 15 of the newspaper that day.
The Washington Post put it closer to the front,
but many pages back from the front page.
Cable channels gave it some coverage.
Fox News barely, but not really anything commensurate
or properly proportional given the scope and
magnitude of the story.
A president not just with the vague idea of
trying to stay in power if he loses, but a
specific plan that he and strategists and
Republican attorneys are discussing.
And it didn't get that much coverage.
And then on top of this, after the article
came out, Brian Carrum asked Donald Trump
at a press briefing, will you commit to a
peaceful transition of power if you lose?
And Donald Trump said, well, it depends on
the results.
Remember this clip from last week when he
has a role in this election?
Will you commit here today for a peaceful
transfer of power after the election?
There has been rioting a lot.
There's been rioting in many cities across
this country, bread and your so-called red
and blue states.
Will you commit to making sure that there
is a peaceful transfer of power after the
election?
Going to have to see what happens.
You know that I've been complaining very strongly
about the ballots and the ballots are disaster
and that people are rioting.
Do you commit to making sure that there's
a place where we want to get rid of the ballots
and you'll have a very transfer?
We'll have a very peaceful.
There won't be a transfer, frankly.
There'll be a continuation.
The ballots are at a control, you know.
And you know, who knows it better than anybody
else?
The Democrats know it better than anybody
else.
You know, for all of the talk about how the
media are so liberal and so anti Trump and
blah, blah, blah, the coverage of this story
was lacking.
The only reasonable answer to will you commit
to a peaceful transition of power if you lose
is.
Of course I will.
Yes.
So there is a real question here.
Why did so many editors who decide what gets
on TV as I lose my Sharpie up, what gets published?
Where in newspapers?
Why did they bury the story?
Dan Froomkin from Salon has one idea.
And the idea is that news editors couldn't
possibly report this story without having
to sound a major alarm.
And that very often editors don't want.
Sound major alarms because they are afraid
of appearing partizan and taking heat and
that this story is so outrageous that you
can't really touch it without making it clear
that this is about does our democracy hold
so that that's why they didn't run the story
or didn't run it prominently or didn't talk
about it much?
I actually think there's a much more dangerous
and disturbing explanation for why this story
did not get the coverage it deserved.
And it's that Trump's base doesn't care about
it.
They don't have a problem with Donald Trump
saying this when 30 to 40 percent of the country
would accept a stolen election as long as
it's their guy who stole it.
Is it really a big story if half the country
wouldn't be outraged?
That is the real tragedy.
They keep being told Democrats are stealing
and committing fraud and all this stuff.
For four years, they've been doing it and
the news is fake.
How do you even get them to care about a president
saying, yeah, I might steal the election or
try to anyway?
This is the end point conclusion of the I
can shoot people on Fifth Avenue and not lose
support mentality.
The bet has been made.
And now how do we get people to stop sleeping
in it?
It is very dark times potentially that are
coming here.
We're going to have more coverage of this
on our Instagram page, David Pakman show on
Instagram.
And if you want something light, because things
are pretty dark, if you want a video of me
chasing puppies around, actually, I guess
the puppies are chasing me around.
It's not clear.
There's a lot of running.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.
We'll be back after this.